[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم صرح رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بان عمليات
قواته في الضفه الغربيه موجهه ضد من دعاهم
بالارهابيين الذين يهاجمون الاسرائيليين
وحمل نتنياهو حركه حماس المسؤوليه عن
اختفاء ثلاثه مستوطنين في الخليل وتوعد
الحركه بدفع ثمن باهظ نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين الى اي مدى يمكن ان تصل الحمله
الاسرائيليه ضد الفلسطينيين والتي بدات
بعد اختفاء المستوطنين
الثلاثه ما هي خيارات الشعب الفلسطيني
للتعامل مع هذه الازمه ومواجهه احتمالات
تصاعدها
[موسيقى]
لم تتوقف حملات الدهم والاعتقال
الاسرائيليه في انحاء الضرفه الغربيه منذ
اختفاء المستوطنين الثلاثه وما زالت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تتوعد الفلسطينيين
وتحديدا حركه حماس بدفع ثمن باهظ اللفت ان
اختفاء هؤلاء المستوطنين كان في منطقه
تخضع للسيطره الاسرائيليه التامه ولم يعلن
اي فصيل فلسطيني مسؤوليته عن الامر وقد
كشف تفج هذه الازمه عن تباين في رؤى
الفلسطينيين بشان سبل التعامل معها ففي
حين دافع الرئيس محمود عباس عن استمرار
التعاون الامني مع اسرائيل اعتبرت فصائل
فلسطينيه هذه التصريحات غير مبرره وضاره
بالمصلحه
الفلسطينيه يختفي ثلاثه شبان اسرائيليين
وهم للتوضيح مستوطنون يقيمون على ارض
تعتبرها الامم المتحده محتله وللتوضيح
اكثر فقد كانوا خارجين للتو من مدرسه
دينيه ويبحثون عن توصيله مجانيه عندما
فقدت اثارهم فيسارع نتنياهو لاعتبارهم
مخطوفين ويقوم جنده بحملات تفتيش هي
الاكبر ربما في تاريخ الصراع واعتقالات
واسعه شملت اسرا محررين واعضاء في المجلس
التشريعي الفلسطيني يجري هذا في منطقه
صنفها اتفاق اوسلو بالمنطقه سي وتشكل نحو
61% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه وخاضعه
بالكامل للسيطره الاسرائيليه امنيا
واداريا فهل هو فشل امني اسرائيلي كان
وراء اختفائهم ام ان الثم مستفيدا قد يكون
نتنياهو نفسه وراء تضخيم ما حدث لهم ان
كان قد حدث فعل قبيل ذلك شهدت اسرائيل
انفضاض دوليا عنها وتراجعا في التعاطف حتى
الامريكي منه معها كما شهدت مصالحه
فلسطينيه وتشكيل حكومه توافق انهت صراع
حماس وفتح والاهم انها كشفت عجز نتنياهو
عن اقناع المجتمع الدولي بمقاطعتها والحال
هذه قد تكون اعاده انتاج صوره الضحيه
ضروره اسرائيليه لاستعاده تعاطف فقد وفرصه
لاعاده الفلسطينيين الى صراعهم القديم بين
تنظيم ورؤيتي للصراع واذا كان ما حدث
اختطافا وليس اختفاء يوثير الشكوك فانه
يعني كما يقول فلسطينيون ان تنظيما مقاو
نجح في اختراق منظومه الامن الاسرائيليه
التي ازدادت تصلبا بعد شليط ويعتبر احتمال
كهذا نتاج عمليه معقده وتخطيط طويل الامد
هدفه تقديم مقاربه مضاده لما تقوم به
السلطه الفلسطينيه لتحرير الاسرى وعددهم
يزيد على ال 5000 فاذا فشلت المفاوضات
فلما لا يكون الحل صفقه تبادل تغلق الملف
باسره بشروط الفلسطينيين وتعيد تلك الجهه
او التنظيم الى صداره المشهد الفلسطيني
احتمالات يقول فلسطينيون انها تظل محفوفه
ببعض المخاطر من مثل ضربات اسرائيليه او
اعاده احتلال بعض المناطق لكنها في
المقابل قد تنتهي بصفقه كبرى تعيد الاسرى
او كثيرا منهم الى اهاليهم بعد ان تعذر
ذلك على طاوله
المفاوضات موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه من رام
الله مع الكاتب والمحلل السياسي س ح شبيب
ومن نابلس مع الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم ومن تل ابيب
شمعون اران المحلل للشؤون السياسيه في
راديو اسرائيل ونبدا من تل ابيب والسيد
ارون من هناك يعني نتنياهو حمل حماس
مسؤوليه اختفاء المستوطنين الثلاثه على ما
استند في هذا الاتهام الذي تبعه وعيد ثقيل
ايضا
لحماس اولا بودي لش اشار الى ان هؤلا هم
ليسوا مستوطنين فهم شبان ومفتيا تبلغ
اعماره بينهم اثنان منهم 16 ونصف سنه
والاخر 19 19 ونصف سنه فهم فتيا كانوا في
طريقهم الى البيت فهم ليسوا جنودا ليسوا
مستوطنين ف وبالفعل فان سريت تحمل حركه
حماس هذه المسؤوليه كامل المسؤوليه عن هذا
الموضوع هناك انتقادات لاذعه ايضا حيال
خالد مشعل من حماس الذي
لمح ضمنا ضمنيا الى للقيام بمثل هذه
العمليه عمليه
اختطاف الشبان يعني هل يعقل ان تبني
الحكومه الاسرائيليه سيد السيد اران عف هل
من المعقول ان تبني هذه الاتهامات على
تلميحات كما تقول للسيد خالد مشعل كما
ذكرتها انت والجميع يعلم انه ليس من مصلحه
حماس ولا حتى تملك القدره اللوجستيه هي
التي حركتها محدوده منذ سنوات وامكانياتها
في الضفه
الغربيه حركه حماس تواصل طوال الوقت
القيام والتخطيط لارتكاب اعتداءات من هذا
القبيل وايضا لاختطاف الجنود وايضا لديها
بنه اساسيه واسعه النطاق للقيام بمثل هذا
الامر وهناك كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات
تدرس وتناقش ضمن المجلس الوزاري المصغر
واطر سياسيه وامنيه واستخبارات اخرى وهناك
اليوم كان والتعاون الامني بين سرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه مستمر على قدم وساق
وهناك مصلحه اسرائيليه وفلسطينيه على هذا
الموضوع كما ان واشنطن ضالع في هذا
الموضوع مع تذكير بان احد المخطوفين لديه
جنسيه امريكيه وجون كيري وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه اذني سيد انا لا اريد اطلاقا ان
اقاطعك لكن انت لا تجيب على على سؤالي كيف
يمكن لهؤلاء ان يختفوا في مناطق خاضعه
للسيطره الاسرائيليه الكامله وفق اتفاق اس
وهناك من يرى بان اسرائيل وحكومه نتنياهو
تحديدا تريد ان تعلق فشلها الامني في هذه
المنطقه على ايه شماعه
تجدها هناك نجاحات عديده وكبيره لجيش دفاع
في المناطق الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
العديد منها لا يكشف عنها في وسائل
الاعلام والقوات الخاصه تقوم ليل نهار
وتقوم وتدافع عن المواطنين الاسرائيليين
من كل هذه الاعتدات الحم سويه على
المواطنين الاسرائيليين كانت هناك عشرات
من محاولات الاختطاف التي تم احباطها على
ج على يد القوات الاسرائيليه ليست هناك اي
فشل من قبل اسرائيل وانما الخطيفي انطلقوا
من اراضي الضفا الغربيه وعادوا الى مناطق
السلطه الفلسطينيه والرئيس عباس و وهذه
المعلومات المعلومات حول قيام حماس
باختطاف الجنود تم استقاها من خلال
التحقيقات الجاريه مع المعتقلين من حماس
وغير من معتقلين خلال عمليات الاعتقال
واسات
النطاق بصوره واضحه انه ان ان نعم ساعود
اليك حتما دعنا فقط نتحول الى رام الله
نتعرف على وجهه نظر اخرى مع الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سميح شبيب نود ان نعرف
كيف يمكن تفسير عمليه الاختفاء هذه
للمستوطنين
الثلاثه ومن باعتقادك المسؤول عن مثل هذه
العمليه بالنظر لما ي ضيفنا الليله من تل
ابيب يعني هذه العمليه جرت في مناطق لا
سيطره امنيه فلسطينيه عليها هي جرت فيقه س
ثانيا ان هذه العمليه عندما جرت ووفق
التنسيق الامني
كان الجدير بالجهات الاسرائيليه ان تبلغ
الفلسطينيين او السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
عن اختفائهم هذا لم يجري هذه نقطه ثانيه
النقطه الاهم من هذا وذاك ان هذه العمليه
جرت في وقت تعيش فيه اسرائيل ازمه سياسيه
حاده نتنياهو بدا يفقد زعامته وهنالك ازمه
سياسيه دوليه تعيشها اسرائيل التي بدات
تتجه نحو العزله انا لا استبعد ان هذه
العمليه مدبره و ومن خلال اطلاعي
الفلسطيني الداخلي لا احد له مصلحه فيها
لا حماس ولا فتح ولا اي فصيل على الاطلاق
هذه العمليه لا تزال مبهمه وعليها اشارات
استفهام كثيره وهي في التحليل يمكن القول
انها تخدم
اسرائيل على اتجاهين داخليا يحاول نتنياهو
ان يستعيد
زعامته التي بدات تنهار رويدا رويدا وان
يستعيد دوره الدولي على انه محارب للارهاب
وهو كما ظهر جليا من خلال جولات المفاوضات
الاخيره انه لا يريد السلام يريد
الاستمرار في الاستيطان يريد الاستمرار في
اعتقال الفلسطينيين وهو يعيش ازمه حقيقيه
سيد سميح عندما يقول الرئيس عباس اليوم
بان من قام بتلك العمليه يريد تدمير
الفلسطينيين ما الذي يمكن ان نفهم من هذا
الكلام نعم هذا الامر واضح جدا يمكن
قراءته على ان هنالك عمليه سياسيه
فلسطينيه
ناجحه كان على الصعيد الدولي او كسب الراي
العام العالمي او جولات المفاوضات التي
جرت مؤخرا مع الاسرائيليين واظهرت ما
اظهرته بان الجانب الاسرائيلي هو الجان
المتعنت هو الجانب الذي لا يريد السلام
نحن كفلسطينيين نحقق المزيد والمزيد من
المكاسب السياسيه المشهوده ه لكن رغم ذلك
اذني السيد سميح هنا هناك من الفلسطينيين
من فصائل تحديدا من راى بان التنسيق الذي
اشار اليه ضيفنا وتحدث عنه ايضا الرئيس
عباس بانه ليس ضروريا وحماس تحدثت صراحه
عن طعنه مسمومه في
الظهر نعم كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل هذه
المناطق سي لا سيطره امنيه لنا عليها هذه
نقطه النقطه
الثانيه التنسيق الامني الذي يجري في
المناطق الاخرى هو نحن
كفلسطينيين نوظف للمصلحه الفلسطينيه اها
كما هنالك بعض الاحتياجات الاسرائيليه
وهذا امر طبيعي بين دول تتشابك
جغرافيتها ولا تزال تعيش فتره حكم ذاتي
وما قبل الاستقلال اها دعنا نتحول الان ل
ضيفنا السيد او الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم
نود ان نفهم معك دكتور انت كيف قرات ابعاد
هذه القضيه برمتها بين من يعتقدها يعتقد
بانها تصب في مصلحه اسرائيل وبين دفاع
اسرائيل عن نفسها بان هذه العمليات متكرره
و بامكان حماس فعليا ان تقوم بمثل هذه
العمليات ونتذكر جميعا في
الخلفيه بانه لا لا مصلحه منطقيا على
الاقل لحماس بالقيام بمثل هذه العمليه في
هذا التوقيت بعد توقيع اتفاق المصالحه ولا
هي حتى تملك القدره اللوجستيه في الضفه
الغربيه مع سنوات التضييق العديده التي
عاشتها نعم وحقيقه الضفه الغربيه هي بحاجه
ماسه الى هذه العمليه والى عمليات اخرى
نحن عبر سنوات
لحق بنا الذل والهوان واسرائيل استهترت
بنا عدوانها يوميا تبني المستوطنات وتصادر
الارض وتقتل وتعتقل وتهدم البيوت وتخلع
الشجر وتنتهك المقدسات كل الموبقات تصنعها
اسرائيل ونحن
بنتفرج كالبلهاء هذا وطننا لا يجوز ان
نبقى مترهلين بهذه الطريقه نحن اصابنا
الضعف واله
واصابت المذله في الضفه الغربيه كان
المفروض على بفصائل المقاومه ان تقوم
باعمال في مواجهه اسرائيل منذ زمن ويجب
انلا تتوقف عن ذلك مع ادراكنا انه اي
عمليه مقاومه ضد اسرائيل ستجلب علينا نوعا
من الضمار هذا صحيح لكن هذا ثمن المواجهه
يعني اي نع من الدمار اعذني فقط هل هو ن
دكتور هل هو نفس الدمار الذي تحدث عنه
محمود عباس بانتفاضه ج جديده ستدمر الشعب
الفلسطيني ام ان هناك خشيه حقيقيه على
المصالحه ايضا بين كل الفلسطينيين التي
تمت مؤخرا لا هو هو عباس عباس يبالغ عباس
يبالغ وكلامه غير متزن ويسيء للشعب
الفلسطيني والعديد من تصريحات عباس اساءه
واضحه وجليه للشعب الفلسطيني واستهتار
بالشعب الفلسطيني هذا غير مقبول اما هل
نتصور ان العدو سيقف متوف الايدي اذاء اي
عمليه مقاومه تحصل لا بدنا نتحمل بدنا
نقتل بدنا نعذب ستهدم بيوتنا ستقتلع
اشجارنا الى اخره هذا وارد لكن علينا ان
نتحمل ومن يقع تحت الاحتلال عليه ان يتحمل
وعليه ان يصبر وهنا اعود الى ال الى عباس
والى نتنياهو واثنين عمالهم يتهموا حماس
كيف ما هو لا ارضيه لهذا الاتهام لا احد
يعلم من الذي قام بعمليه الاختطاف وبارك
الله به على ايه حال لماذا لانه ادخل
اسرائيل في اهانه كبيره اسرائيل تغطرس
وتفرد عضلاتها امام العالم وانه لا يوجد
من بين العرب من يقف في وجهها لا اتى من
قال لا قفوا نحن سنقف بوجوهكم واعتداءات
المستمره على الشعب الفلسطيني يجب ان
تتوقف فاسرائيل كان كانت تقول انه ا
اجهزتها الامنيه لا تخترق الان لا هي
مخترقه وغير قادره على معرفه اسرار مثل
هذا العمل وانا اقول طبعا لاسرائيل اللي
معك انه اسرائيل انه حماس اذا كانت هي
التي قامت بالعمل فهذا ليس عدوان العدوان
هو الاحتلال اسرائيل هي الدوله الارهابيه
هي الدوله المحتله التي تمارس احتلالها
على الشعب الفلسطيني كل يوم وتمارس
الارهاب في لحه ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي من حق الشعب الفلسطيني ان يرفع
السلاح في وجه اسرائيل لكن وهذه الرساله
لعباس ايضا نحن لا نتوحد الا لا نتوحد الا
في ظل المقاومه اللي بفرقنا وبخلي
المصالحه تنهار كلام عباس وليس المقاول
تما ساعود اليك دكتور يعني بعد ما قلته
بان هناك ثمن كبير سيدفعه الفلسطينيين
جراء هذا الموضوع برمته وزير الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي والسؤال هنا للسيد شمعون اران
وزير الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي قال سنحول
الانتماء لحماس لتذكره جهنم وز ايضا رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي قال نحن في طريقنا
الى حمله كبيره ستنفذ خططنا بالترتيب لها
وناهيك عن العديد من التهديدات
و للعديد من للفلسطينيين طبعا من نود ان
نعرفها الان خلافا او غير العمليات
العسكريه وغير حمله الاعتقالات الشديده ما
الذي تحضر له
اسرائيل ايه اولا بودنا الاشاره الى انه
تم اعتقال الليله الماضيه زهاء 53 معتقلا
من ضمن السجناء الذين تم الافراج عنهم في
اطار صفقه شليت وهؤلاء سيعودون الى السجون
الاسرائيليه بسبب خرقهم ل تعهداتهم وشروط
الافراج عنهم كان عليه مثلا كانت عليهم
قيود على تحركاته في الضفه الغربيه كان
عليهم التوقيع على مذكره مره في كل شهرين
واعادوا ايضا الى ممارسه الارهاب هؤلاء
السجناء المعتقلين الخ سيعودون الى السجون
الاسرائيليه هناك لجنه
خاصه القاده حماس في الضف الغربيه الغ
المطقه الوسطى في جيش الدفاع
وترح هناك نعم كانت هناك جلسه جلسات
متتاليه ل المجلس الوزاري المصغر وتقرر
مثلا المساس بظروف ظروف سجن المعتقلين
السجناء من حماس مثلا تقليص عدد الزيارات
العائليه من مره في كل اسبوعين الى مره في
كل شهرين والعديد من ذلك والمزيد من ذلك
كانت هناك مثلا ابعاد كان فكره ابعاد
السجناء من حماس المعتقلين من حماس الى ق
غز اذا العديد من الخطوات وضح تماما سي
سيد شمعون وضح تماما مضطرون الان ان ناخذ
فاصل قصير سنعود سنعود سنعود للنقاش
سنناقش بعد هذا الفاصل خيارات الفلسطينيين
للتعامل مع هذه الازمه ومواجهه احتمالات
تصاعدها ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
والتي تناقش ابعاد الحمله الاسرائيليه
المتصاعده في الضفه الغربيه بعد فقد ثلاثه
مستوطنين هناك وخيارات الفلسطينيين في
مواجهتها نعود مره اخرى لضيوفنا مباشره
الى رام الله والمحلل السياسي سميح شبيب
سيد سميح يعني سمعت ما ذكره ضيفنا من تل
ابيب المزيد من التصعيد الاسرائيلي على
الفلسطينيين هذا ما سيميز المرحله القادمه
على خلفيه
هذه الحادثه والسؤال هنا الى اي
مدى التتابعات التي ستكون لهذه العمليه
على الفلسطينيين انفسهم نود ان نعرف خاصه
وان ليس كل الفصائل كما ذكرنا موافقه على
رؤيه السلطه في التعامل مع هذا الموضوع
والتنسيق الامني وال يعني ما الخيارات
التي يمكن ان تتاح للتعامل مع هذه
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه التي يخشى فعلا ان
تقوض المصالحه
الفلسطينيه
يعني اسرائيل اتخذت من هذه العمليه
ذريعه
للمزيد من الاضطهاد المزيد من الاحتلال
المزيد من الانتهاك اسرائيل دوله عدوه
اسرائيل ما دامت تحتل الارض وتغير
الجغرافيا
والديمغرافيا هذا امر غير مقبول نحن
نقاومه ولكن بالعقل نقاومه وفق معادلات
دوليه و اقليميه
نقاومه وفق مصالحنا الوطنيه الان نحن
وحماس والجميع هنالك عنوان سياسي حكومه
الائتلاف الوطني هنالك خطى نسير بها وصولا
الى الوحده الكامله ما بين الضفه الغربيه
وقطاع
غزه سيد سميح اعذرني ماذا لو قررت اعذرني
لو قررت الفصائل الفلسطينيه التصعيد على
خلفيه هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي قررت هي
ايضا تصعيد الميداني اي خيارات تبقى امام
السلطه
الفلسطينيه نحن الان نصعد خطاب ابو مازن
هو كان واضحا هذا اليوم وكان واضحا للغايه
بان هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي له اهداف ما
معينه منها ضرب وحده الشعب
الفلسطيني منها اظهرنا نحن كانها هنالك
جبهه ارهاب وجبهه اسرائيليه ما معينه تريد
الحفاظ على المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا امر
غير صحيح على الاطلاق الامور باتت واضحه
المجتمع الدولي بات يدرك الامور والشارع
الفلسطيني بات على وعي كامل لمصالحه
ولمستقبل هو يسير حثيثا نحو الاستقلال
وهذا الاستقلال يحتاج الى حاضنات اقليميه
ودوليه ومجتمعيا وغير ذلك انا اعتقد ان
مخطط اسرائيل الذي يتدحرج
الان سيؤدي الى فشل ذريع والى مزيد من
العزه اسرائيليه والى مزيد من اظهار
اسرائيل على انها هي الدوله العدوه للشعب
الفلسطيني وللحريه
لاستقلال وللسلام في المنطقه وضح سيد سميح
دعي نتحول مره اخرى الدكتور عبد الستار
يعني حدود التحرك باعتقادك المتاحه الان
امام الفلسطينيين فصائل وسلطه في مواجهه
ما تتوعد به
اسرائيل نعم يعني يجب الا نقلل من درجه
الانتقام الاسرائيلي على الرغم من ان
اسرائيل لا تع لا تعلم من الذي خطف ونحن
لا نعلم لكن الانتقام الاسرائيلي سيكون
شديدا وربما يكون اشد على قطاع غزه وان
اسرائيل ستعمل على قصف اهداف عديده عسكريه
ومدنيه في قطاع غزه وربما تلجا الى
الاغتيالات الاغتيالات
السياسيه الان ما هو الرد وما هي الخيارات
امامنا الخيارات انه يجب ان نصبر اولا ام
نحن بنعرف ويجب ان نعرف انه هذا الوطن لا
يتحرر الا بالصبر والاراده الصلبه
والمواجهه مع الاسرائيليين اما اننا ل
بدنا نستنى الاوروبيين والامريكيين حتى
يعطف علينا ونعمل دوله مستقله لا يوجد
دوله مستقله من خلال المفاوضات ولا من
خلال ما يسمى بالمجتمع الدولي هذا نتركه
جانبا لو كان في خير كان ه عبر هال 20 سنه
انجزنا شيئا حتى الان نحن لم ننجز شيئا لم
يتغير من واقع الانسان الفلسطيني شيء
الشيء الثاني انه الفصائل الفلسطينيه ايضا
يجب ان تبقى ايديها على الزناد وخاصه في
غزه نحن في الضفه الغربيه المشكله انه
السلطه الفلسطينيه جردت الناس من
السلاح هي لاحقت كل السلاح الذي يمكن ان
يوجه ضد الاسرائيليين وابقت على سلاح
الزعران الذين يمكن ان يشي ان يسيئوا
للشعب الفلسطيني اما في غزه لديهم
امكانيات المقاومه نحن نعرف انه حجم
التدمير الذي يمكن ان يلحق بغزه لكن لا
مجال الا ان ان نواجه من غزه ان نضرب
المواقع الاسرائ والاهداف الاسرائيليه ودع
الامور تاخذ مجراها الان ما حصل ايضا في
الضفه الغربيه
عمليه الاختطاف هي ايضا رفعت من معنويات
الناس في الضفه الغربيه اعطتهم بعض القوه
بداوا يشعرون انهم يمكن ان يكونوا اهلا
للمواجهه اهلا للانتصار لوطنهم وبالتالي
يعني يمكن ان تتطور الامور في الضفه
الغربيه الى ان تكون هناك انتفاضه
جماهيريه مخلله او موجود فيها بعض اعمال
المقاومه يعني انتفاضه لوحدها لا يكفي
وانما يجب ان يكون هناك مقاومه لتدفع
اسرائيل ثمنا مثل ما يدفع الشعب الفلسطيني
ثمن فبالتالي نعم في خيارات امام الشعب
الفلسطيني المشكله انه السلطه الفلسطينيه
هي اكبر عائق امام هذه الخيارات وتحاول
تحجيم الناس حتى لا يواجهوا اسرائيل اشكرك
جزيل الشكر للاسف شديد وقتنا انتهى تماما
كنا نود ان نناقش نقاط اكثر اشكر جزيل
الشك شر الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم المحلل
السياسي الذي كان معنا من نابلس كما نشكر
جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من رام الله الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سميح شبيب ونشكر ضيفنا من
تلبيب شمعون اران محلل الشؤون السياسيه في
راديو اسرائيل بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه دمتم
في رعايه الله والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه